I heard too recently I didn't get to see
it but I've heard everybody talking
about it when Taylor's surprised and
Kelsey was on there as well was that I
mean because that's hilarious how the
commentators it's not hilarious how it
is literally taking over the NFL for
people that like watching sports now and
like you have to watch like a a tutorial
it's like you're watching Housewives
while you're watching yeah they're just
talking about gossip things and you're
like so what about the play right yes
yes can but they're taking over right
yeah I thought it was funny that y'all
that's what I love about SNL y'all touch
on it like right then it's so awesome
that it's live and you're able to like
attack those things like at on the
weekends like right when it happens
right it was crazy like we no one for
fresh material oh yes yes thank you
Travis and Taylor for that um it was it
was it was so wild we didn't expect them
to come I around the corner they're at
the page desk and it's like I'm like oh
there's two of the tallest people I've
ever seen who are they right who is that
I was like I was like in the redwood
forest or something the Mirror Woods yes
yes and then I was like oh my goodness
wow it's them okay they're here and it
was it was wild oh I love that so you
went to her aist tour right yes I went
to yeah I wasn't able to make it so I I
I imagine it was just first of all it's
such a clever idea to do that and have
everybody go because there's so much
Nostalgia happening for people that have
been fans for so long were you have you
been a fan for like a a minute I've been
a fan for a a a long minute a long
minute were you afraid to say decade you
and it's wait it's been about a decade
cuz I really I I latched on during red
oh great yeah yeah great album um no so
it's it's been a minute and um you know
we've we've we've all grown up with her
and so it's it's it was so cool I
watched it from the floor and then with
Matt Matt my friend Matt Rogers and I
went and then we and then but then
seeing the Aras tour movie yeah cu the
movie came out the movie came out and it
was everywhere I literally ate at a
restaurant here downstairs and we were
leaving Katlyn who was serving us was
like Hey and I made these bracelets and
she said something and for the debut or
something and I was like I just went
along with I was like thank you that is
so nice and then I walked off we're like
what are they talking about and they
were the people are so into it they were
making people just Rand are making like
bracelets passing them out to like she's
got such an incredible street team I
know I was like yeah amazing but yeah so
the movie came out and it like busted
all these like you know stats and
Records yeah yeah which is not shocking
it's Taylor not at all yeah but I love
that you've been a fan for so long I
think we're we've all been a fan of her
music she's a great writer like she's
got so many great
songs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home